ginger Zee may not be able to perform on
the dancing with the stars finale a
source close to the show tells ET the
Good Morning America meteorologist
suffered an injury to her pelvis which
is causing a back spasms pelvis was
forward and today it's completely back
so its flipped in a day which is just so
my muscles are freaking out
thirty-five-year-old Z is taking it easy
in hope she gets to perform a Monday
night if she is able to compete Z will
face off against model nyle DiMarco and
a UFC fighter Paige Vanzant last week
ginger told ET she was already I think
the pressure for me is to do better than
I have so far but to do better and feel
better when we're done with that dance I
want to look at bell and I want him to
be beaming I want him to be so proud and
so happy and like not that nothing went
wrong or that you know once one toe was
out of place put the feeling that we got
and the feeling in the room was the best
performance that we've given that's the
pressure